we have a picture of you from I believe
you were
you've brought a picture of yourself on
a canoe trail these were these are from
Instagram I think somebody stole these
yeah go ahead what what do you got this
looks like you're about to die okay now
that is not a Photoshop that's a real
photo why are you still alive well
because because I'm a I'm actually a
badass the face you made after you said
I'm a badass not bad betrayed betrayed
you just actually want I guess you went
well actually because I'm a badass
[Applause]
okay no III did it that is actually a
cool picture because it's on the
Chattooga River which is the border
between South Carolina and Georgia and
and it's the it's the river that
deliverance was filmed on oh my god yeah
that's a dark dark movie yeah and can I
tell you the even weirder part is that
the counselors showed us the movie
deliverance in in order to like prep us
for the rapids because because we ran a
lot of the rapids that it doesn't be
definitely doesn't prepare you for the
rap no it scars you for life yeah it's
ridiculous yeah no I mean dumbest thing
I've ever heard in in their defense they
fast forwarded through yeah the insane
disturbing parts which only makes it
more disturbing yeah in fast most also a
third of the film yeah you know yeah
it's like we're gonna show you Scarface
to get you ready for visiting Florida
you know well kids what you think
you